first of all congrats on the movie uh I
really I had a really good time with the
sequel
um and I have a lot of questions but I
like throwing something a curveball at
the beginning you have done so many
different things through your career if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've done what is the first thing you
want them watching and why
I would love for for them to watch the
eight movies that I have done with Pedro
malova for example why because
it's a cinema that it was done in my
hometown in my I mean in my home nation
actually in Spain
um because I think they broke many
different rules of cinema at the time
that they were uh you know made and uh
and because it's it's pure Cinema I
think so I I just will show the people
that and then you know there are other
things as you said you know very
colorful a round of my career that
complement that thing but those eight
movies for me are very important what do
you think it is Puss in Boots has been a
breakout character since the beginning
and has been so popular for so long what
do you think it is about the character
that has resonated with so many people
for so long
contrast
you know
there's something that is important I
mean when the the Shrek Saga was created
they were just putting a lot of accent
in all fairy tales and just taking up
those characters
a completely different look to those
characters that before you know a
different angle to see them uh Zorro in
a way was a fairy tale it was created as
a stripe on the New York Times before we
went to the biggest screen and then to
television in the 60s and stuff so they
took the character like a fairy tale
character but they put their whole
entire character in the body of a of a
cat that is a contrast and then that
little cat you know has a very strong
voice
those little things is what made is the
source of Comedy it's almost like the
character never looked at himself in the
mirror like he doesn't even know what in
the look that he has is he got a
personality that is bigger than his own
body and it just traveled with that and
then you know he got a kind of a double
uh phase you got a face for kids
and he had a face for adults you know it
was very funny some interviews that we
did yesterday some of the of the
interviewers they were very very young
they were like I don't know 26 27 years
old and so they saw the fresh like 20
years ago that the first participation
that I had and they got a perception of
the movie that was completely different
to when they revised the movie 20 years
after they said to me things like you
know when I saw the movie now of Shrek 2
for example I understood why my father
was laughing at certain points that I
couldn't understand so you know the
intelligent in the teams that were
creating all of those movies was
extraordinary just to create a movie
that appeals to uh audiences that were
you know adults and for the kids at the
same time I think that's the success of
[ __ ] boots I have read about a sequel
to Puss in Boots for a good 10 years now
and I honestly wasn't sure it was ever
going to happen uh were you ever at any
point where you like this is never going
to get made
at some point yeah at some point in
which I you know that I lost contact for
maybe a couple of years
um but I knew you know that you know the
studio operate big changes because he
moved to another Studio actually to
Universal and that and at the same time
the pandemic came on so there was a
number of things that were going on at
the same time so uh I I got in contact
with them eventually but yeah there was
a period of time of like a no maybe not
two year but a gear I have something in
which I didn't receive any news another
point I thought oh well maybe they're
just rethinking and you know because
this new Panorama that they had in front
of them you know they're thinking in
something completely new they didn't
want to revisit things that they have
done in the past something like that so
yes at some point I thought about it but
but then here we are uh I don't want to
do any spoilers however the movie does
introduce the possibility that plus is
about to see some friends
um you know um maybe Shrek and other
people have you heard anything about
another Shrek movie and another
adventure
um no officially no no no nobody has
said anything to me there I was the
first one who was surprised when uh at
the end of uh of this movie we saw this
uh wink of an eye that the studio just
threw there with far far away and so I
don't know I don't know if it's gonna
happen but certainly I if I knew
something I would I would say it but you
know non-officially I I definitely want
to know um because when you're making it
you really don't know how it's all going
to come together even you what was your
reaction to the finished film because I
thought it was a lot of fun
uh the thing that surprised me the most
was
the capacity that
you know
that we all I guess had to create a
moving which we allow ourselves to
reflect about issues that normally you
don't in front of a very young audience
uh the possibility of the character
dying uh and you know the depression
that he get into and at the same time
the panic and you know of seeing death
very close to him all the time in a
metaphorical character almost that the
wolf represents and then the
vulnerability of this hero you see a
hero now that he can just be in trouble
you know psychological trouble just
fighting the idea of death so that I
think it was important and I think after
the pandemic and having kids you know
confined in the houses with masks going
here and there without sharing a school
time with the friends you know and
seeing from their homes that out there
there is something danger that is
threatening them yeah I think it's
important that instead of hiding we just
show them you know uh a reflection about
the importance of existence and life
itself listen before around the time
with you I have to ask you I am a huge
Indiana Jones fan and I just want to
know what it was like when James Mangold
said hey we want you to be part of this
movie and being part of the last Indiana
Jones movie with Harrison Ford it was
great you know uh but you have to think
my character is very little it's almost
a cameo it's a it's very little just
just the fact that I step on the set for
me was important uh and and I think I
gotta tell you I got a great time with
Harrison he's a gentleman on the set and
outside of the said I share some dinners
with him and some time and
what a gentleman but my character is is
a little you know it's uh he's just a
friend of Indiana's character and he's
looking for him because he needs
something from from his friend and but
but that's it you know he just takes a
very little time of the movie but very
happy to be part of a saga that is
history of of the history of Motion
Pictures obviously for sure listen
congrats on this I wish you nothing but
the best and um thank you for your time